[Music]
skyline of houston there where a doctor
says he was punished for trying to save
lives and this morning he's ready to
strike back dr assan gokal was fired
from his job and charged with a crime
after giving out covet vaccine doses
that were on the brink of expiration
this was at the end of last year when
vaccine doses were often very scarce and
apartment and appointments were very
hard to find our lead national
correspondent david begneau is in
houston for us where we've just learned
that dr goelkel plans to sue the county
government that fire this has always
been a perplexing case david good
morning
good morning we just confirmed through
sources that within the next 72 hours dr
hassan gokul is expected to file that
lawsuit claiming that he was fired on
the basis of race and national origin
look the headlines were really big and
prominent international when the story
broke doctor accused of stealing covet
19 vaccine people were shocked how could
you do that but the headlines were not
as big and prominent when the entire
criminal case brought by the district
attorney against dr gokul completely
fell
apart breaking news a harris county
public health doctor is facing charges
for stealing a vial of the covid19
vaccine it was on the local news where
dr hassan gokul says he first found out
that harris county district attorney kim
ogg had charged him with theft by a
public servant did the da's office call
you no did you hear from any
investigators no
nobody no here's how this all started it
was december 29 2020 vaccines were just
rolling out nationally and harris county
was having its first public vaccination
event and dr gokul was the supervisor at
the end of the night he said there was
one open vial with 10 doses left in that
vial and they had to give them away
within six hours or they were going to
expire i made a quick call to the
immediate supervisor said hey
i've got
a few extra doses i'm going to find
people to try and give them to and the
answer was okay
i started making phone calls to people
that i thought
would know
somebody or might have
contacts who may
benefit from that vaccine
specifically in the high risk categories
zara ahmed was one of them she works at
a doctor's office and her mother who
lives with her has parkinson's disease
she defends dr gokul how was a stealing
i mean i i don't think it was
there's no way you could call this
stealing
dr gogle says when there was just one
dose left and less than an hour before
it expired
he gave the vaccination to his wife
maria who has pulmonary sarcoidosis
which is an inflammatory disease of the
lungs the next day he says he turned in
all the paperwork for the 10 doses that
he gave out and eight days after that he
said his hr director said he wanted to
see him we heard that you uh
my that you took a vial
and vaccinated your friends and family
with it what am i
are you talking about
the first day of vaccination when there
were leftover vaccines
and i took them and i found 10 people to
give them to
oh you admitted
well i'm gonna have to terminate you
you guys were gonna throw these away and
i found people to give them to
he said well but you know the other part
of it is is that you didn't do it
in a
in an equitable manner
are you suggesting that there were too
many indian names in the group
he points fingers exactly
the investigation report from the
district attorney's office stated that
the hr director did say that the patient
forms that they had identified were
individuals of the same nationality as
dr gokul so at that point it looked like
the forms belonged to friends and family
two weeks after dr gokul was fired the
district attorney put out a press
release claiming that dr gokul abused
his position to place his friends and
family in line in front of people and
that he disregarded county protocols but
five days later assistant district
attorney kimberly smith told dr gokul's
lawyer in an email that there were not
any written protocols at that time
nor was there a wait list harris county
judge franklin bynum reviewed the
district attorney's case against dr
gokul and he found that there was no
probable cause to charge the doctor
based on the
the information they provided me that
not only had they not proven that there
was theft but that they had gone about
it in a way that was pretty incomplete
and pretty sloppy two months later the
texas medical board cleared dr gokul of
any wrongdoing but the d.a persisted and
four months after that she took the case
to a grand jury and the grand jury
declined to indict dr gokul the
spokesperson for the district attorney's
office told us that the grand jury has
spoken and we greatly respect that
adding given grand jury secrecy and the
possibility of civil litigation
involving the county it would be
inappropriate for the d.a to participate
in an interview
paul doyle is dr gokul's attorney well
that's ironic because she finds herself
in front of every camera whenever it's
self-serving to her say sorry okay how
about say i got it wrong
this has been incredibly incredibly
devastating and there's no other way to
put it tell folks why you did what you
did
i did
what a physician would do
which is
take resources meant for patients and
people and give it to them
instead of throwing them away and that's
why it was so infuriating